It's about time to get even one dimension more, heat conduction in 2D.
So, we're talking about temperature distribution that depends on time, on x and as a premiere on y.
One way for visualizing this is a movie.
Each frame of the movie depicts the temperature distribution in x and y
at that precise instance of time, then we come to the next frame of the movie
which shows us the next distribution in x and y and so on and so on
and what we expect to see is diffusion.
If there's only one hot spot at the beginning, it should gradually dilute over time.
The heat equation in 2 dimensions does not contain any surprise.
The partial derivative of the temperature with respect to time
equals α times the second derivative of the temperature with respect to x
plus the second derivative of temperature with respect to y.
Note aside, this expression is often called the Laplace operator applied to T.
Don't confuse this triangle with the delta. It's also often called the Laplacian.
You can imagine the Laplace operator to measure something like
the bend of a surface in 2 dimensions and there's a very simple
finite-difference scheme for that differential equation as well.
Now, we're looking at one point at the current time and the current values left and right,
below and above to compute the next value at that central position.
That next value is temperature after one time step at x and y and we can spell out our estimate.
This is the value before times 0 x and y plus the time step
times the diffusivity divided by the spatial step size squared and now we got lots of terms
The values of our function to the left, to the right, below, and above all at times 0
to the left (x - Δx0₁), to the right (x + Δx), below (y - Δx), and above (y + Δx).
Hopefully, it's not already confusing that I'm using Δx to also denote the increment of y.
Now that we've covered the outer point, the inner point remains.
In one dimension, we are to subtract twice the value of the inner point.
In two dimensions, we have to subtract four times its value.
It's easy to see that this has to be a factor of 4. Imagine that it's equal to 100 Kelvin everywhere
then we get 100 + 100, (+), (+) makes 400.
We subtract 4 times 100 so we get 0. The new temperature will be old temperature as it has to be.
There's nothing that could be smooth out if the temperature is already constant in space.
This factor out 4 also hints at what's going to happen with instability.
We have to be even more picky about the step size.
It can only be half as large as in the one dimensional case.
And the other artifacts that we are going to see close to instability are checkered board patterns.